a queen and golden armor like wow
the moment is almost upon us our
precious has returned and a lot of sweat
tears and actual forgery went into
bringing us the rings of power are you
prepared to find out what stunts went so
wrong and what design choices went so
right a lot of what you see on tv
will be what we saw on the day as well
number one here we thought they just
hired actors with big feet i think that
people will really enjoy the half foot
world i really do but turns out that the
prosthetic hobbit feet were a pain to
navigate sarah zuangobani who plays
marigold brandyfoot found the prosthetic
feet were actually really challenging at
first but we had this incredible team of
people that helped us with them kept
refining them which by the end they
became part of us
number two three stunt people were
seriously injured
dana grant had a head injury after being
scanned she found out she had an eight
millimeter brain aneurysm and an upper
spinal injury aka her neck she had to go
for surgery alyssa cadwell suffered a
serious injury in february and was paid
500 000 by amazon and thomas kiwi
injured the rotator cuff in his right
shoulder so bad that he left the
production yikes number three so if you
were complaining about the vfx we've got
news for you the opening sequence was
done entirely with practical effects
that's right the title was forged in
studio special effects advisor douglas
trumbull said there are magical things
that happen in nature gravity fluids
lighting that one couldn't really design
using computer graphics
that forging was done by pouring an
alloy mixture of bronze and aluminum
into molds of compressed sand it was
filmed at a whopping 5 000 frames per
second with a phantom flex 4k camera so
it could be shown in ultra slow motion
number four the orcs were mostly
practically created but why does that
impress people of course the production
required a lot of them and the ones that
are further back are cgi the rest of the
orcs were played by actors but the
closer to the camera they were the more
detailed applications they had executive
producer lindsay weber said that they
worked really hard to make the
prosthetics super thin and more
comfortable but added there are times
when they're wearing things teeth for
example and sorts of other stuff that do
make that hard they tried to use real
prosthetics and minimize the visual
effects because the audience can see
them they were really supportive of what
we wanted to do and they were excited
about what we wanted to do number five
an elf and a dwarf walk down a hallway
together what could go wrong the single
most complicated scene is just that
doesn't sound so complicated in theory
however patrick mckay explained it best
saying you have to shoot everything
twice so it will be down to the
millimeter mimicking the exact same
moves and then the two things get
spliced together and create this effect
of one person being taller and smaller i
think we take this responsibility really
seriously number six ditch the dresses
stick with armor it's bigger than me it
was bigger than us cynthia adai robinson
was over the moon about her costume the
queen in golden armor is nothing to
scoff at i had all the armor on and this
incredible helmet and this is all
conceived by kate holly our amazing
costume designer what specifically left
her in awe is it didn't feel like they
feminized the armor in any way she
thought her character was going to be
dressed in things like flowing gowns but
no and i just thought oh my god wow
number seven do you think anybody offers
group rates on spelunking the original
idea for the underground dwarf realm was
to have it set under a mountain in new
zealand however once they factored in
the hundreds of crew who would have to
go spelunking just to get there the
danger and the expense were enough to
have them film on a sound stage and
create the set from scratch number eight
despite their bragging about practical
effects a ton of cgi was used so the
show isn't entirely without its vfx of
course and places you may find it is
when you get into stunts in action
including the things humans just
physically can't pull off the prosthetic
beasts and creatures needed further
advancements in slight ways as well
really built as much as they could so
that we could actually react off
physical
sets and despite their claim that not
many vfx were used
9500 were that's more than the original
lord of the rings trilogy and the hobbit
movies combined number nine now we shall
take a look at venice or rather middle
earth venice the set is filled with all
kinds of different intricate details
like the pulley and lever system they
used to lift their horses while it may
come across as a simple moment it shows
how advanced they are as a society to
have thought of it production designer
ramsay avery said we looked to art based
in egypt north africa and the middle
east to inspire the bold shapes rich
colors and geometrical ornaments that
are central to the mediterranean
sensibility of this kingdom another
particularly important influence was
venice italy thanks to one comment made
by tolkien i just got back from numenor
i mean venice number 10 we aren't
talking dragon scales here the scale of
characters in this tolkien franchise was
all over the place and quite possibly
one of the biggest challenges the actors
faced so they had to go to scale academy
for a few hours to learn about the
technicalities of the work i think
that's quite surprising
yeah i agree i agree number 11. these
boats are actually sailable ramsay avery
said we keep trying to find something
that said numenorean as opposed to
pirate ship the long triangular sails
represented the elves ships and we
needed something that stood on its own
for numenor one night i was looking
through some pictures and i saw the
crown of gondor i'd always thought of
that crown as eagle's wings but i looked
at it again and i thought my god that's
a ship's sail there number 12. the
security measures may sound intense
aggressive security measures were taken
to keep the writing a secret the windows
were taped closed and they had a
security guard doing fingerprint
clearance for anyone entering the
writer's room number 13. core
characteristics make it easier to write
about different factions director j.a
biona broke down the different worlds
each faction lives in saying i mean it's
such a rich and complex universe and so
different so if you want to go for
nature you would find the harfoots if
you want to get more political you will
go to the elves there's more melodrama
when you go to humans it feels very rich
and complex and i really enjoy it a lot
working with each of the worlds it was
like a perfect balance between
the map that somehow talking established
and having a new source material number
fourteen ain't it the dream to rise to
stardom with your college bud actors
benjamin walker and robert armaio went
to the same college which ben claims is
the reason for such success in the show
in their shared shorthand communication
which he can't help but compare to their
characters and also their bond saying i
do think gilgalad and elrond do kind of
share an unspoken communication gilgalad
recognizes that the half elf needs to
prove himself and gilgalad also
recognizes that there is infinite
potential for him and he just needs a
little guidance
i like it it is it it should matter it
does matter number 15 we knew it would
cost a lot but nobody anticipated this
much the rings of power is the most
expensive tv show ever made with a
budget of nearly 1
billion dollars we wonder if that's
before or after the half a million
payout to cadwell amazon beat out
netflix in the bidding war for the
rights at
250 million good people doing good work
in a great show
it's really gratifying the rings of
power has huge shoes to fill are you
excited about the new tolkien spin-off
or are you worried it won't live up to
expectations let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things